continue d'en parler avec notre invité
michael greenberg des chefs du service
de la reproduction et préservation de la
fertilité à l'hôpital antoine béclère de
clamart bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors on vient
d'entendre les arguments des
manifestants aujourd'hui à ce que vous
les comprenez les gens tendent ce qui
vient maintenant je vais pas vous dire
que je comprends et je je défends je
vais défendre ça puisque ce projet de
loi aujourd'hui c'est une deuxième
lecture au sénat ça fait plus d'un an
qu'il est en discussion et préalablement
ça il y avait énormément de travaux qui
avait été fait c'est une preuve
une promesse d' emmanuel macron quand il
était candidat à l'élection donc il ya
rien de nouveau
et certes nous sommes dans une crise
sanitaire il n'empêche que on ne peut
pas empêcher les choses d'avancer c'est
une loi qui est discuté depuis longtemps
c'est une promesse de campagne et il est
qui est attendu par nombre de femmes et
bon nombre de personnes dans la société
alors ça revient beaucoup à la
marchandisation du corps humain pourquoi
cette loi bioéthique et vu un signe par
certains je crois qu'en fait c'est les
gens de la manif pour tous font pour
tous ont toujours une tendance à vouloir
revenir vers la gpa et la pma ça n'a
rien à voir
la gpa la gestation pour autrui est
souvent associée à une marchandisation
du corps une langue c'est une femme
c'est un couple de qui a besoin d'une
fade pour porter un enfant et qui va qui
va souvent avec souvent de la
marchandisation pour que cette femme
accepte de porter l'enfant est donnée
cet enfant à la naissance
là on n'est pas du tout dans ce contexte
là ce sont des couples de femmes qui ont
besoin d'un don de sperme des donneurs
de sperme y en a il y en a pour les
couples hétérosexuels
car on a besoin pour les couples
hétérosexuels on n a jamais prier et ces
gens là n'ont jamais crier à la
marchandisation du corps humain quand
c'était des couples hétérosexuels qui
avait besoin d'un bon de ce terme
quand l'homme du couple n'était pas
capable de les produire donc on est il
faut il faut arrêter de mélanger tous
les débats on n'est pas du tout dans la
même problématique la la la pma qu'elle
soit pour les femmes célibataires ou les
femmes homosexuelles fera appel au don
de sperme le don de sperme irna il y en
a toujours eu et il a jamais posé de
problème et il n'est pas associé à une
marchandisation
oui vous me disiez un amalgame et
entre la gpa et la pma autre mélange
entre li wenjie et l'imc
on en vient à cet amendement qui fait
débat celui autorisant une interruption
médicale de grossesse donc une img
jusqu'au neuvième mois pour détresse
psychosocial beaucoup finalement cru que
c'était un délai d'allongement de l'ibg
vous pouvez vous nous expliquer en quoi
concrètement consiste cet amendement
l'amendement le but c'est de nos jour
d'hui en france nous avons le droit de
faire d interruption médicale de
grossesse quand il ya une maladie d'une
gravité importante qui nécessite si
jamais on sait que l'enfant va être mal
formés ou atteints d'une maladie
particulièrement importante en il est
possible d'interrompre une grossesse
jusqu'à jusqu'à la veille de la couche
là donc ça c'est aujourd'hui c'est acté
et ses rangs cris et ça n'est jamais ça
n'a jamais été remis en cause après la
question de la détresse psychologique al
des femmes et la possibilité d'étendre
cette interruption médicale de grossesse
dans ce contexte là aujourd'hui
bien entendu que c'est une possibilité
mais ça va être particulièrement encadré
il faut pas croire qu'on va se mettre à
faire des interruptions volontaires de
grossesse pour des femmes jusqu'à
jusqu'à neuf mois c'est pas ça la
réalité c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer et c'est interruption médicale de
grossesse pour des presses psychosociale
ce sont des drames qui se passe pour les
femmes c'est pas une femme qui se dit
c'est pas le bon moment pour moi d'avoir
une grossesse et c'est verrouillé par x
commission avant de pouvoir lactée parce
que nous savons en tant que médecin que
mettre un terme à une grossesse pour un
contexte psychosocial qui n'est pas une
problématique médicale au sens premier
du terme avec un risque pour l'enfant à
proprement parler un risque médical et
bien dans ces situations-là et liens
dans ces situations rare mais pour
lesquels elle pense qu'il va se passer
possiblement un drame pour l'entendre ou
pour la mer et lien il y à il y aura
dans des cas exceptionnels la
possibilité d'interrompre la grossesse
alors il ya des manifs et des contre
manif sur ce projet de loi à bioéthique
on voit bien que c'est un sujet
écrivant est ce que finalement le texte
a été assez bien expliqué on est sur une
sur une thématique est complexe et qui
qui a fait qui fait débat depuis depuis
la nuit des temps d'ex qu'on a trait à
la reproduction et tous ces sujets là
ont toujours été très controversée avec
des pour et des contres vous savez comme
moi avec l'époque déjà de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse a déjà posé un
certain nombre de problèmes et on a vu
des opposants et on a des opposants
permanent à cette interruption
volontaire de grossesse dès lors qu'on
est dans des évolutions qui concerne la
reproduction
on a toujours un groupe de personnes qui
vont être contre toutes ces évolutions
qui vont dire que tout doit se passer
naturellement qu'il ne faut pas se baser
sur la médecine
même pas pour aider les couples
hétérosexuels qui n'arrive pas à avoir
d'enfant puisque il faut savoir que dans
ces lobbys y en a qui sont contre la pma
tout court y compris pour les couples
hétérosexuels et en a qui sont contre
les le diagnostic prénatal
quand on doit pour faire des recherches
de trisomie 21 ou autres pour des
interruptions
donc en fait on va toujours avoir des
problèmes relatifs à ces questions de
reproduction c'est pas pour ça qu'il
faut pas avancer la majorité de la
population est quand même en faveur de
ces évolutions
parce que la société évolue et on se
doit de faire évoluer notre médecine au
regard de cette société michel nikkei
merci à vous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous est chef
du service de la reproduction et
préservation de la fertilité à l'hôpital
antoine béclère de clamart marciac